every Friday we're gonna be taking the
time to answer your most pressing
questions rather about the coronavirus
and this morning we are talking about
testing testing in its accessibility and
what could be the best option for you
now diagnostic testing determines if you
currently have the virus while the
antibody blood tests check if you have
previously been infected CBS News chief
medical correspondent that's dr. Jon
LaPook joins us to sort it all out Jon
always good to see you let's talk let's
talk about all these new testings that
are coming to these tests it let's talk
rather about the new tests that are
coming on the market like the saliva
test every day we hear about a new form
of testing so how do you know which one
is the best one for you to take it can
really be confusing Gail canape and that
saliva test is really interesting but
let's just review the test that goes
into the nose in the back of the throat
that's the PCR and that's to look if you
have active virus they're looking for
viral particles right or evidence of it
the blood test is looking for an
antibody
it's called serology and it's to show
whether you've been exposed it doesn't
say whether you have active virus in
your system now that saliva test just
came out of Yale I took a look at it
really interesting you know people don't
like the the swab being jammed in the
back of their nose it could be very
unpleasant and they found that it was it
could be just as good it was a small
number of people that were tested about
40 for people who actually were ill and
about 98 people who were health care
workers who were followed and actually
they found that it might even be a
little more sensitive
I wanted to know exactly what it was did
you just spit into a jars a little bit a
bit of spit they said it's about a third
of a sterile urine container so it's not
a little amount of spit but more study
has to be done with that it'll be really
interesting to see if that ends up being
better because I think it could be more
widespread you don't have exposure of
healthcare workers to the possibility of
getting infected you could do it at home
and then send it in I do like the sound
of that I always find John when doctors
say something is unpleasant or
uncomfortable it's going to hurt so we
have a question from Ann great question
she says I thought you could only get
tested if you're symptomatic and have a
doctor's note
she asked this
why do the experts say testing is so
important when you won't be able to be
tested I think this is a really great
question especially after Adriana's
piece the last half hour where a medical
worker couldn't even get a test from her
own Hospital yeah absolutely and let's
just start off by saying we absolutely
still do not have enough widespread
testing you know we we don't have the
ability to test every single person who
we want to test with either test with
either the diagnostic test or the
antibody test now of course if somebody
is sick you want to know if they have it
that's pretty obvious but when you're
talking about wanting to open up parts
of the country and whether it's safe you
have to know not only is there active
virus in people so you want to just test
people randomly to see if people who
don't have any symptoms are carrying the
virus but also you want to get an idea
of what's been going on in the last
several months you know so many of us
during the winter Gale had a little bit
of a cold a sniffle a sore throat chills
diarrhea we're hearing about all these
different symptoms that can be
associated with kovat 19 and coronavirus
infections so we want to know well maybe
I was infected that's the antibody test
and if we do that more widely then we'll
get an idea well how prevalent was it in
the last few months was it just a couple
of percentage of people was it much
higher we saw a little bit over 20% of
people tested positive in New York City
is it reliable so there are so many
questions that we need to know before we
open up parts of the country because
otherwise you're doing it blindly and
the symptoms keep changing so I hear you
say that even if you don't have symptoms
you should get tested here's a viewer
question from Carol Ann on Facebook she
says when will the antibody test be
actually correct I'm gonna correct that
actually sorry even if you don't get
tested you should be even if you don't
have symptoms you should be tested
that's a tricky question that's people
who when when public health officials
are trying to figure out who in the
population may have been infected and
what's going on in terms of community
spread those are the people without
symptoms who should be tested otherwise
if you don't have any symptoms and you
weren't exposed to somebody who had
symptoms and there's no other reason to
do a test and the CDC in this state have
list of people who get tested with
either one of these tests like health
care workers first responders people who
are sick people who were exposed etc etc
it can be really confusing you have to
talk to your doctor about whether you
get tested but it's not I'm not saying
that everybody should get tested right
now although I think if there were 300
million tests it would be nice to test
everybody but we don't have that right
now yeah okay thank you for the
correction I just know everybody's so
nervous everybody wants to get a test
but your Corrections vary of course John